el código genético del coi 19 ya no es
el mismo que fue identificado en wuhan
el cotejo global da cuenta de que han
sido descubiertas al menos dos
mutaciones cada 30 días se trata de un
proceso natural pero aunque en febrero y
junio ya habían sido reportadas dos
variantes más en europa fue hasta
diciembre que aumentó la preocupación
por la que fue detectada en reino unido-
desde septiembre a diferencia de las
otras esta presenta al menos 17 cambios
o alteraciones simultáneas lo que la
lleva a figurar como una combinación
única la mayoría de sus alteraciones
afectan en la proteína s también llamada
como pico o espina esta funciona como
una especie de llave del virus para
entrar en las células
al incidir sobre esta proteína las
alteraciones logran aumentar su afinidad
por el receptor lo que se traduce en una
mayor facilidad de contagio todavía no
hay pruebas de que esta variante sea más
letal todo apunta a que sólo influye en
la transmisibilidad en reinounido está
logrando reemplazar con rapidez a la
variante inicial
se estima que en promedio puede ser
hasta en un 70% más transmisible ante el
interrogante sobre si esta variante
podría ser tratada con las vacunas más
avanzadas hasta el momento expertos han
afirmado que tanto la de facer como la
de astrazéneca y la de moderna coinciden
en su mecanismo de acción todas se
prenden al sistema inmunológico para que
pueda atacar las distintas partes del
virus entre ellas la de la proteína s
para los expertos esta variante refleja
la manera en la que el virus se adapta a
medida que se propaga por lo que llaman
a los ciudadanos a evitar más rebrotes
ya no llevar de nuevo a los sistemas de
atención médica por el camino del
colapso